[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about how
technology and government shape society
we have some warrior joining us on the
show hello
it's good to be back number two for you
yeah yes almost a year ago was our first
episode together we've had a whole year
to update our mental maps and I'll sit
back down together and talk very excited
to be talking about the subject you are
social scientist and founder of Bismarck
analysis which analyzes organizations
and governments for clients and you can
find some Mo's links below to his
website his Twitter and his new YouTube
channel which we highly recommend
subscribing to very powerful short
bursts of intellectual deliciousness Wow
so strong endorsement strong endorsement
yes yes well when you analyze why
civilizations fail and succeed I think
that give that is a very important point
for people to know and learn about so so
we're really excited for this round two
let's start things off somehow with the
analysis of the current state of
humanity ah that's definitely a very big
topic and I think almost everyone senses
that they should be thinking about it
much more than they actually are I think
almost no one is delivering a detailed
look through all the relevant aspects
and I think if we're going through all
the relevant aspects we should make sure
that we look at knowledge we look at
power we look at the state of human
connection as such I think looking at
knowledge first the biggest changes that
have occurred in like the last twenty
thirty years has been a change in how we
consume information we have
straightforwardly gone from centrally
administered information that is
consumed in a synchronized manner by all
of society you know the TV show that
would empty the street or the newspaper
editorial everyone would talk about has
been replaced by like a broader
ecosystem where people are reading
different websites at different times
have different interests different
niches watch whatever show they will uh
Netflix and while there definitely start
still our trends this sort of like
there's no longer this common media
heartbeat that used to exist that has
immediate consequences for power as well
the great great power still exists
states nation states still dominate the
world scene they move around armies they
move around economies this game has been
in motion for a few hundred years it's
not yet stopping though the rules are
changing and new actors are entering the
space because of the new nature of media
governments right now are grappling with
how to interface with it how to regulate
it America has its own approach China
has its approach European Union has its
approach now as well these will play out
in different ways and they'll affect how
every one of us uses the Internet and
they'll also affect how propaganda is
produced in society how mass opinion is
altered how marketing works further
these nation states have to contend with
the centralized influence and power of
individual social media companies social
media companies represent the true
newspaper editors of our era because
they can dictate in a way much more
strongly than comfortable with admitting
what can go viral and what cannot go
viral when things exist on the wild
internet anything could go viral but if
something exists on a platform such as
Twitter or Facebook or YouTube things
can be boosted or things can be D
boosted as like on the almost
euphemistic term they use internally is
now of course like there should be some
management of like forums of platforms
of conversations we want to keep things
civil we don't want you know unnecessary
hatreds to be inflamed but on the other
hand like who is making that call and
who is making that decision and is it
made transparently or not I think for
the most part right now the companies
have a vastly outsized
ability to influence public opinion at
least in the West they're probably using
it without government oversight now of
course I'm not saying government should
be managing public opinion directly
though in practice historically this is
what's always happened in nation states
through everything from the education
system do like public propaganda
up to including large physical rallies
where people who gather and listen to
leaders and so on right so how is this
gonna be navigated will the companies
rise up and end up dominating
governments where politicians will chase
poll numbers and the poll numbers will
be you know determined by the board of
Facebook or will the government step in
a nationalized Facebook and we'll have
something like more like directly
Orwellian or will we find a way to be
free enlighten individuals and we'll be
able to participate in a public release
course where the ideas of many many
people enrich us right where the
information environment isn't one of
predation and domination but of actual
free exchange of information I don't
think we have a solution for how to
engineer this last outcome it's one that
I would dearly like to see in the world
but I feel the frontrunners are the
first two outcomes right the first year
outcomes being social media companies
dictating public opinion or government
dictating public opinion and that's you
know that's unfortunate that's an
unfortunate situation
now I mentioned connection I think that
interpersonally people used to have
notably better social skills and then do
do right now for whatever reason the
process of atomization said in motion in
the 19th century continues now this has
perhaps some positive effects like some
harmful traditions can be abandoned but
it's also the case that people find
themselves much more isolated from each
other than they ever were and they
consume social media as a substitute for
actual socialization like there's like
this anonymous presence or perhaps there
are people under pseudonyms or perhaps
people are liking each other's photos
instead of meeting in person and whether
you know we have to acknowledge we're
still very much physical creatures we
need human touch we need human
companionship we learn and can see
things in person that we can see via a
tweet like a tweet is now I think 280
characters so we're maybe slowly
evolving back towards essays it'll take
a few more doublings before we reach
that point but there are things you
can't put in those characters you can't
put in words that are visible
immediately not just from a simple
picture or
not just for video but from the highest
definition thing there is the physical
presence of another human being
discussing ideas and responding to you
in real time no lag cool so that's my
summary of the human condition right now
yeah so knowledge power and connection
right making a human connection man
connection yeah on on the on the
knowledge front of things I am very much
so on the side of being able to
disseminate memes faster yeah we that's
beautiful technology enabling that while
simultaneously the the the
signal-to-noise ratio we're not exactly
sure how that's been affected by this
opening of the mimetic propagation so so
that that's another potential question
to figure out is is is are we
disseminating high quality signal to the
rest of population science and this
foundation of collective knowledge that
we've accumulated do you do you feel
like that we're propagating more signal
I mean that's a very interesting
question I've noticed something because
I end up talking to interesting people
over and over again I seek out both
intellectuals and exceptional
individuals who are often shaping the
world in various ways and I notice
consistently older Internet users by
which I mean people that have used the
Internet for 20 or 30 years so not the
people that are old they just discovered
the Internet but people that were there
in the 1990s they are actually quite
good at finding the most interesting
ideas of 2019 so whichever the skills
they use to develop back in the days of
the wild Internet still serve them quite
well so they seem to have good
signal-to-noise ratio people that are
used to relying on search engines still
have a decent signal-to-noise ratio now
the search engines have their
limitations but in fact for most people
this was a massive breakthrough enabled
them to do like this kind of research
and sifting through the haystack to find
a needle that would have been just
impossible the auto suggestion functions
that we see in the platforms I discussed
earlier the walled gardens of the
internet as they have arisen
well those don't require an active
doesn't require any active action by
individuals at all you we have in fact
come full circle to being back the
passive consumer except instead of
whatever television programming has in
store for you this afternoon you can sit
down and just see what the autosuggest
serves you you don't even have to pause
to consider what your query is right
when you when you put something into
Google you're considering a query a
search term right you have to think
about that on the other hand you can sit
on Facebook and just scroll down your
feed and the feed will provide well what
has the feet decided to provide you
that's an interesting question yes so
this brings us back to like you know who
determines what's what's what's the
signal and what's the noise yeah I think
a lot of things that are dismissed as
noise are actually very strong signal
there is not yet properly understood
that's right and a lot of the time once
you learn to adjust for like a bias that
exists in the signal the signal is once
again accurate right it's the kind of
thing where if you had something simple
in physics you had weight measurements
and you realize all of them are off by
exactly two you know two pounds in one
direction well lo and behold you now
have accurate weight mass from
measurements again because you just
adjust all your measurements for that I
think there's a very real learning
process that's happening where we often
emphasize the technological side of the
spreading of memes but we don't really
talk about how individuals are now
educated to consume memes that's right
memes when they show up can be very
potent can change your behavior for good
reasons or for bad reasons second time
that has developed already it's kind of
like not immune response but you have
digested it you have predigested what
you're seeing it doesn't have the same
impact again and then again and again
and again and eventually what
crystallizes is a culture of media
consumption movies when they first
showed up they would have people run out
of the movie theater when they saw an
approaching train on screen because they
were terrified they had the same
emotional experience as if the train was
really gonna go run them over no modern
movie go over goer would ever have that
response my propaganda posters were
introduced they
a very strong effect on questions of
like I should I enlist in the army or
not today propaganda posters don't
really work on people anymore now this
goes both ways right you can say well
what about public smoke you know public
anti-smoking campaigns public health
campaigns
maybe those are less effective maybe you
know let's let's not wait into
vaccination or whatever but let's for
the sake of argument say all the
vaccination stuff completely true deeply
useful an important public health issue
well it could be that the measures we
used to convince people to all get
vaccinated and acquire herd immunity are
failing and that the anti-vaxxer thing
is less a failure of good or bad science
but a change in what people causes
people to be receptive to persuasion
right because people were persuaded by
the posters by the announcement by the
Surgeon General by you know their
personal doctor their physician telling
them that you know they really should be
vaccinated and perhaps that's no longer
persuasive right so the way people
respond to memes also changes a lot of
the memes we a lot of our memes live on
the inside they live in our heads and a
certain amount of memes circles around
and is shared between us by a mediums
such as like again internet
communication books institutions but I
think heads store more mean memes than
is usually acknowledged and these
interact with each other I think you
bringing up the principle of critical
thinking is extremely important here
that it's not just about the way that
the memes are distributed via technology
of how people consume them how people
consume them what is our methodology for
critical thought and making sure that
the seeds children that are born into
the world have the deep critical thought
of able to hold tons of abstract
contrasting perspectives on single
issues at a given time I'm happy you
brought that up and this is again this
is kind of you know pushing forth as you
mentioned earlier with human connection
as well is what is happening to our
ability to be able to empathize and get
behind each other's eyes at some levels
some technologies enable that more and
also other levels it seems as though
we've lost some of the millions of years
of AI to AI of our ability there and so
that's kind of an Internet's effect
society and will be will be chiming on
this as we go to I want to show Ronny
you want to show the image of the chip
first and then I want to show that image
because the the chip for computer
processing has now been following
Moore's law we're entering into quantum
computing era it seems as though
processing is now more than ever one of
the most massive aspects of human
knowledge computation and dissemination
and also the first image with this is
that is the shipping and transportation
of this 90% of all world trade happens
by see we've had a globalization occur
with these eight billion humans on the
planet so these things coupled together
with the Internet's effect on
civilization as well as these words
power knowledge and human connection is
a very good way to interpret the current
state on things and what are your
thoughts as that as the internet is
taking such a massive amount of of our
engagement on a daily basis hours and
hours and hours of time on the internet
every single day what does it seem as
though is occurring with our ability to
be watched as we are on the internet you
kind of gave it earlier a little bit
with their query we're using the Google
substrate or volley Babur Baidu or a
ten-cent and Facebook as substrate to
query on to and then we're relying on
their algorithms to be nuanced and
multivariate and the right unity
oriented what are your thoughts about
those substrates and a global
surveillance state well there's an
interesting question here I think first
off one of my basic principles is that
knowledge is good so the positive side
of everyone's spending so much time
online is that for the first time ever
we have a vast record of human behavior
this is amazing we could use this to
truly understand humans in a way that
we'd never have done so before all
anthropological study studies of the
past were done by a particular
individual just observing people writing
down small notes
then we had anthropological studies
where perhaps sometimes people were
recorded well now we have something like
two to three billion people right that
are always being watched this means we
have this huge pool of information we
could learn new things about humans
things we could not figure out
previously but then comes like the power
aspect again human what is predictable
is in a way a manipulatable right and
that's why mass surveillance is to be
truly interesting it's less I mean it's
it's of course bad when a authoritarian
or totalitarian government perhaps
process you know persecute people that
it shouldn't be persecuting there's this
idea of like hunting down the lone
dissident yeah I kind of think the
technological capacity to hunt down the
lone dissident was pretty advanced
already in the 20th century he already
had things like you know they would bug
people's apartments they would bug phone
lines there have teams of people trying
to find well who are these who are
either activists revolutionaries or
reformers that we just don't like and
this was used in power struggle between
different factions within systems like
that of the Soviet Union or Communist
China or you know arguably even the
United States of America and it's more
common you know it's more turbulent
periods like the 60s or maybe the the
early 1990s but the interesting thing
here is that mass surveillance not as a
tool necessarily of government spying
but as a tool of government policy is
something that we've not truly faced if
the government can know reliably thanks
to the power you know showed computer
chips earlier you know compute has
massively increased compute unlike just
the interconnectedness of the Internet
allows us to run advanced artificial
intelligence algorithms allows us to
process masses of data these two to
three billion humans are not just
watched by other humans trying to study
and learn about other human beings they
are basically data that's processed
economically at scale because the
possibility to process data economically
and scale combined with people are now
under consistent observation
means that there is a possibility of a
deep kind of micromanagement that we
have not yet seen in human history it's
very easy to object on it it's very easy
especially from the Western from a more
American perspective to be like well you
know I want to be a free individual or
from an idealistic perspective you know
I I just want to be a being on this
earth I don't want to be part of this
vast system but what if their economic
gains to micromanaging citizens in this
way what if their productivity gains
what if their military gains what if the
government literally can make sure that
you're brushing your teeth every morning
and deducts points if your phone notices
you haven't that sounds really bad in a
way but what if it works and if it works
we might be forced into a system that's
higher on compulsion even as the nominal
like indicators of our life improve even
as perhaps lifespan is slightly longer
or with somewhat richer but in a way our
authority for individual decision making
has been devolved to central authority
and how central authority is no longer
even a human being in a way but is this
decision-making process that's still
like running the name of a human being
again either the board of Facebook or
some circuit government entity or
something but you know in in a way
that's a sad outcome that's an outcome
where human agency has left the world I
think there has to be a strong response
to that and I mentioned previously
economics and you know global shipping
is a great example
the reason globalization happened is not
because everyone wanted to be
interconnected as human beings
necessarily but because the economics
were good yes it was better it was
better and cheaper to ship something all
the way from China to the United States
or from the United States to Europe
let's remember that also happens then to
produce it locally right and as soon as
you could have something that's like 50%
cheaper a hundred times cheaper perhaps
then it becomes a no-brainer you're out
competed by those that participate in
globalization definitely if you try to
opt out of globalization isolate
yourself you're going to be just a very
rich you're going to be a very
impoverished Society in an ever richer
world so that's why we should fear
I think the company I'm eeen fear I
almost want to say if you're yes we
should we should avoid the outcome of a
mass surveillance state that uses a lot
of algorithmic data to optimize our
lives even if the nominal results are
good mm-hmm
because that would be a locking down and
narrowing of the destiny of humans as
individuals and of humanity as a whole
there are definitely ways to do this
well in a more decentralized way in a
way that empowers individuals you know
if if my phone was actually my personal
assistant with the information belonging
to me and I could set the parameters on
what kind of behavior I want to
encourage in myself
that's a notable step forward that's
humanity plus it's not humanity - but
then setting that up so that that
happens not trivial at all now when I
said fear I was thinking about it as I
was saying it I don't think it's very
useful to be afraid of futures even if
they're dystopian futures it's much
better to carefully think them through
and one of the things I've always
learned is that fear is not conductive
to thought so think about it
contemplated perhaps even accepted and
then deviate from that undesirable
future there's so much of our society
right now where we are too afraid to
look at things you know the United
States is too afraid to look at what
happens if China becomes the new
dominant superpower we are too afraid as
individuals to consider that you know
perhaps we're no longer making our own
decisions
we are too afraid to perhaps consider
that you don't decisions are being made
non transparently so we default to a
simple civics class version of how our
governments work even though we
personally if we ever worked in an
office environment know that those
principles aren't upheld yeah I went
quite deep into answering this yes you
should bring me and if I go just yes oh
you you're synthesizing a lot of
different complex information and though
one of one of the ones that you
mentioned is how to how to write the
code of technology to maximize human
chelyn human sovereign tree this is a
very interesting point rather than
having it on a global surveillance level
as it or is there a way for us to own
our data and use our devices to help us
live better lives that are aligned with
our divine will and our and our purpose
in in the world while simultaneously
hopefully spiritually evolving to a
point where even on a transparency level
maybe some of the some of the
surveillance isn't even needed at that
point because we are such well behaved
primates on the planet hopefully
hopefully right and now you mentioned
this earlier we talked we were just
starting to shift us into the direction
of what happens on an economic level if
China is able to outpace the United
States and I think that what we're
seeing is in many ways a Pareto curve a
distribution with China in the United
States being at the forefront and then
so many other countries being at the
tail and so it's it's looking like in
some of the some of the images that we
have here are some of the leading
companies and countries around the world
and we have that one of the ones we have
is is jobs and Tim Cook and this is of
course this is with Apple one of the
highest valued companies in the world
and then we have Sergey Brin from Google
with Prince Mohammed bin Salam
Salman Salman of Saudi Arabia Saudi
Arabia which a very interesting walk and
talk I'm sure is happening there and
then we have Elon Musk of SpaceX and
Tesla and then lastly we have Chi
shipping of China as well and so what is
your synthesis on the out innovation of
China out competing the United States as
well as just the role that these
companies further play in countries
further play in the development of our
world well will China out-innovate the
United States is an extremely
interesting question some of the names
that were just brought up in this like
short slideshow are beacons of
individual innovation in the United
States
right Steve Jobs's Apple came to define
the tastes of a generation but also
produced the smartphone as a true device
I unfortunately don't expect to be
surprised by Apple anymore this is
perhaps an indictment of the company the
company maintains its good taste but
will not build the next iPhone building
the iPhone it is however now
manufactured in China you can only
invent an iPhone once where it's
manufactured well that's a matter of
economics so that technology while
pushed forward the wild frontier is
pushed forward you get to encode what
you want in the technology itself you
get to set it defaults very quickly
technology becomes the property of all
in a way technology like self globalizes
it encourages copying everyone
understands and viscerally sees the
power of a technology and wants it for
themselves and if they copy your design
perhaps the code continues right the
smartphone as we know it has taught
humans new things about how to use it
and how to relate to each other they
could have easily been taught to do a
different thing perhaps would have all
been wearing around Bluetooth headsets
or something we would add voice
interface instead of like you know
screen interfaces we now can't imagine
something different and we also we saw
Elon right Elon is single-handedly
making America a leader in the space
industry wouldn't thousands of others
that build of course of course of course
his vision is definitely something that
inspires the engineers that work there
and the general decisions allow you know
allow things such as funding to come to
the engineers that work there and they
get to work on projects that they
understand are trying to get people
eventually to Mars in a very real sense
the mission statement of SpaceX isn't to
maximize profits it's to go to Mars
and I think going tomorrow's inspires
engineers much more than making a profit
the profit is nice and you should have
it if you can make consciousness inner
planets Iraq Electrify earth with
vehicular transportation right right and
now going back to the China comparison
the big question in my mind is will
China produce such visionaries and
exceptional individuals as Elon
as Steve Jobs well maybe right there
governments all over the world to try to
court people who are already exceptional
visionaries please come to here there's
a Saudi Arabian city called
neom where the Saudi government is
trying to make it a middle-eastern
center of innovation make it a city
extremely friendly to technology and
development having heard about various
problems San Francisco has had over the
years such as you know housing
homelessness unreasonably high living
expenses you might imagine well it's not
that hard to unseat the capital of
Silicon Valley and move Silicon Valley
somewhere else in the world perhaps into
a new city hundreds of thousands of
powerful nodes as yes it's an
undertaking but it's been done before in
history right so my question is well can
China attract foreign talent and can it
generate domestic talent I believe it
definitely can generate domestic talent
but does this talent have the space in
Chinese society to fulfill their vision
with Chinese society punish or reward an
Elon Musk punish or reward a Steve Jobs
here you have an interesting trade-off
the Chinese Communist Party has
consistently viewed individuals that are
pursuing unique ideas I guess they're
not coming from the center as possible
threats
there's delicate balance to be had in
their mind between the authority of the
party the authority of the government
because from the Chinese perspective
they went through a devastating civil
war not once but twice in the 20th
century first in the warring States
period after the fall of the you know
Qing Dynasty and then in the war between
the Communists and nationalists forces
and the immediate aftermath of World War
two
they price stability and unity yeah but
if you prize stability and unity too
much you can end up stifling out
alternative visions because the end of
individual inspiration goes out to the
community to the thousands of workers of
SpaceX
they in fact are receiving and building
upon and expanding and realizing and
co-creating the vision Elon has set for
them but if you spot that down then they
can only co-create the vision of this
central organ of society so China I
think can create a city much more easily
than Saudi Arabia that can attract the
most talented creative minds of the
world it can give these creative minds
special privileges but unless it will be
able to generate and foster such spirits
in their own society their society will
also fail to innovate so there there
there I would think if the Chinese
create space for individual thought in
their society they will in fact they
will in fact out compete the US and if
not the lag behind this relates so much
to your post on great founder theory
when you look at the individuals that
you've been describing and we've been
showcasing here a lot of their ability
to galvanize humans around a vision is
so beautiful because yes yeah then you
can make tremendous advancements in
updates in civilizations code and this
has been seen as a burden of genius from
dr. Thomas Starzl so the Wright brothers
and all the way back to when photography
started even before that when the wheel
and language I mean this these things
have been coming and so much how do you
galvanize other humans around a central
vision that can update civilizations
code for the better and I love that
theory around being able to to do so and
that's a huge inspirational point can
China inspire a great founder theory can
the United States continue to inspire
great founders what will happen with the
Middle East and Europe and Latin America
so many Africa so many other places in
the world have the potential to update
civilizations covariate founders and
with the unleashing of creative
potential and leapfrogging of
technologies I want to ask you about
some of the power struggles that are
happening on the planet right now what's
happening Israel and Palestine Pakistan
and India Venezuela these things are
pretty much what one could even say more
than ever there are little pockets of
come back on bat around ideas and even
more so alternative countries
involvement in these places for natural
resources so what are your current
thoughts around these little pocket
that are happening well I think India
vs. Pakistan is the most worrying one in
India vs. Pakistan you see Pakistani
state that is unfortunately a little bit
in a state of a dissolution
this might sound relatively benign so
whatever country is in a state of
dissolution well it means that there's a
fragmentation of its military forces
where it's military forces want some
kind of confrontation with India their
perspective is in the long run India's
economically outgrowing us and will
force whatever outcome it wants right
now we can perhaps still win a war the
Government of Pakistan of course like
you know no one goes into war easily
doesn't want such a war while noting to
India it is very much willing to defend
itself and willing to defend its
particular interests India's perspective
is different well we have a border
dispute we both claim this area the
catchment province yes exactly we share
like some cultural heritage and all of
this you know they both have a strong
claim to the history of Indian
civilization this isn't usually
discussed but Pakistan straightforwardly
is also an heir to ancient Indian
civilization as much as India is there's
a layer of religious conflict Hindu
versus Muslim yeah India is the world
one of the world's largest Muslim
countries it has a large Muslim minority
it's a minority only in India could 200
million people be a minority but they
are Pakistan almost overwhelmingly
Muslim right so any conflict between
India and Pakistan will have spillover
effects and will shake the pillars of
Indian society itself yes so the Indian
government's aware of this and in a way
does not want war with Pakistan either
however if a military faction is
pursuing war against you you can't be
completely certain that this is not a
decision by the central government of
your opponent imagine if the height of
the Cold War a Russian or an American
general unilaterally attacked forces of
the other side could an American
President or Soviet premier truly
believe a story by their counter
part that oh this was merely a rogue
general this is not the beginning of a
full-scale invasion you know it's very
difficult to believe such a statement of
trust is low and between the weak
Pakistani government and the Indian
government that is facing challenges on
many sides including the rise of China
there exists a history of bad
communication the two states formed in a
very difficult period after the end of
British colonialism in many ways
mirroring conflicts and other fragments
of the British Empire such as northern
Island where the existed conflict
between the Protestant Irish and
Catholic Irish with the Protestant Irish
being descended from English settlers
and the Catholic Irish seeing themselves
as as you know true natives and in India
that the Hindu versus Muslim struggle
nearly resulted war in fact the two
countries have gone to war numerous
times since if a nuclear exchange
happens there I predict an Indian
victory I predict many millions of
people will die and even in an Indian
eight victory
the remaining Indian society will be
shattered and it will be a humanitarian
disaster of untold proportions we will
have easily 90 million refugees from
such a situation the economic progress
of the subcontinent would be set back
and trust in fellow man around the world
would be decreased a nuclear war would
then no longer be this hypothetical
terrible thing that could have happened
during the Cold War but suddenly becomes
a normal thing that occurs every now and
then mhm a thing that could happen to
our country so the first effect of it
would not be oh no nuclear weapons are
terrible we should disarm the first
effect is going to be nuclear war
happens we should arm right that's going
to be the the security in the state
logic so that's why I think that
conflict is the most worrisome of the
ones listed
Israel on Palestine is an interesting
example of the struggles of people to
find like a good peaceful coexistence
the most interesting aspect there is the
delicate balance of power that exists in
the Middle East as a whole where you
have Iran that is trying to expand its
sphere of influence trying to acquire
States to be its allies in a twist you
know in a twist compared to the
intention of u.s. foreign policy
planners in the early 2000s Iraq has now
become an Iranian Ally because the Iraqi
government is Shia dominated so in the
Middle East as the Sunni versus Shia
conflict Iran a--such finds itself
opposed to Israel but because the
shia-sunni conflict exists ironically
Saudi Arabia has quite aligned interests
with Israel in particular their interest
is a containment of Iran also they share
an interest in not having states that
are too powerful in the immediate
vicinity Saudi Arabia's military is
relatively weak such a military can't
really compete with an army of even
another Arab country even if it was a
Sunni Arab country the Iraq of Saddam
Hussein was at one point militarily
powerful and it was dominated by the
Sunni faction yet Saudi Arabia was quite
concerned and let's remember that Iraq
invaded Kuwait when they saw how
successful the Iraqi invasion of Kuwait
was they probably considered how
successful in Iraq invasion of Saudi
Arabia might be which is why they called
on and even assisted us u.s. engagement
and us waging of war with Iraq yeah so
the interesting situation there is that
in theory you know in theory as a
religious duty the Saudi state should
have never assisted non-believers
fighting believers right if you use that
typology but the history of religion and
politics has always been politics first
religion second religion use more as a
justification than a true cause of
international action the security
concerns tend to dominate this is true
in medieval Europe you would have a
fruitful alliance
between the kingdom of France and the
Ottoman Turks at the Ottoman Turkish
Empire a Muslim and a Catholic power
will were they fighting well probably
the Protestants or the Spanish or
whoever else they had no immediate
conflict of interest and a common
interest in say weakening the hapsburgs
and this has not changed in the modern
era at all so a lot of the things that
happened in the israeli-palestinian
conflict as such are caused by these
larger calculus of the entire region
where people decide to back either the
Palestinians or decide to back the
Israelis or decide to you know intervene
in a nearby countries such as Syria that
calculus flows from the great powers
downwards to these small conflicts these
small conflicts are often seen as
indicators that the area itself is
messed up more frequently however it's
not just that the area itself has
legitimate endemic problems but it is a
wound a reflection of these larger
tensions in the world as such Venezuela
is an interesting case of a country that
was trying to unseat us geopolitical
dominance in South America in some ways
you could argue that the you know
deplorable state of living conditions
there right now is the result of
failures of socialism of redistributing
production to some to some part this is
true but in some part it's also the
difficulty of attempting to build a
politically independent entity in a
world where economic ties are a vector
of political influence US sanctions on a
country like Cuba and Venezuela I'm not
going to say whether such sanctions
should or should not exist there many
good reasons to have sanctions against
such countries but the truth is the
sanctions do make the countries poorer
than they would be otherwise furthermore
there's always the question of well how
paranoid should a government be against
insurgents against revolutions and so on
and one of the strongest reasons to be
worried about an uprising in your own
country is if you fear that might be
foreign support coming in
funding rebels right those again to go
all the way back to Pakistan in India a
big concern of the Indian government is
quiet Pakistani support for terrorist
groups so that that would be a quick
scan of the world there yeah and I
really I feel as though this has a lot
to do with our ability to spiritually
advance ourselves toward this unity of
collective prosperity and actualization
that if we could get there faster we
could avoid so many of the conflicts
that we have but this is a very
difficult puzzle with a billion
deferring perspectives and opinions and
power struggles and and authorities over
knowledge and process of Education and
it does seem to be also a bunch of codes
that are competing the code of what it's
like to be Hindu versus Muslim the code
of what it's like to to compete with the
we didn't even mention China's belt and
Road initiative it's like a code of code
of wanting to economically prosper your
your country by by economically
advancing other nations but then what is
there what are the agreements are they
lopsided or they asymmetrical agreements
so there's these these questions of the
codes of the technology companies as
well as the countries themselves as well
as religions that are all in a big
melting pot that's mixing together to
eradicating suffering maximizing
prosperity the objective function is
there it's just how do we how do we all
agree on how to take the steps to
actually get there I have a question
from the audience
yes let's have the audience question
right let's bring it up on the on the TV
okay there we are that's very
interesting question I think
can yes that's it well for those that
are just listening on our audio
platforms we have a question from aunt
Kay cook who says how can Western
society continue to form collective
intelligence and update its young with
relevant skills and knowledge and I
believe this is Anthony Anthony reached
out to us from the United Kingdom he's a
graduate student in physics I believe
and he he's just been in touch with our
channel as well it's good to hear from
you thanks for watching Anthony yes and
participating right port I mean it's
it's a really tough question the best
answer I would have is that we should be
moving towards the world where we allow
high agency individuals to express that
agency as much as possible and that
can't be done in a standardized
bureaucratic context it has to be done
via leaving spaces open I think without
the ability to act a lot of learning
never happens because there's a unity
between Furion action this unity has
been you know degrading in very serious
ways for a very long time I would argue
at least a hundred years because it's
much easier to organize a formal
education process where everyone has
given theory then to organize social
structures such there is room for the
multiplicity of action and agenda we
discussed earlier the problem with China
well China's in many ways different but
it's not that different there just a
little bit more on the spectrum towards
order and stability and they're more
towards the spectrum of well perhaps
this is a challenge to central authority
the United States has some elements as
well I think that on a good-enough
set up stability order are not in
contradiction with creativity and growth
what is more unstable and fragile than a
stagnant non-adaptive system that will
be a short-lived system such a system
can only last 50 years or hundred years
it can never last 400 years or even a
thousand years
a system that can last a thousand years
is a self transforming an evolving
system to make it more concrete I think
we should probably abolish elite
education by which I mean not abolish
education but abolish the credentialing
chokehold held by the Ivy League
universities they put a stamp on your
forehead that says you are given
economic opportunities or you're not
given economic opportunities I don't
know perhaps you should do something
radical perhaps we should enroll half a
million students a year in Harvard
if Harvard is so good for you and it's
teaching you so many wonderful things
why shouldn't we democratize Harvard why
the economic why the constraint on the
supply correctcorrect why are you
constraining supply well you know
cynical argument might be that Harvard
is a hedge fund attached to a school for
tax purposes right and then you might
say well perhaps their calculus is
guided primarily by how to get students
that will maximally you know that will
give the biggest possible donations back
to you sure right in and how to and
maximize the value of the small economic
Network still though because so much of
the online open educational platforms
now enable some of the enable scaling
radical scale yeah yeah and so universe
a reform of the top you know or reform
for tertiary education so these these
top universities probably need to be
opened up I think it's possible for us
to scale like the delivery of theory
there and we should Deacon strain the
credentialing system so that you know a
simple like piece of paper is not the
key thing that enables or not economic
opportunity you can imagine even more
fundamental transformations imagine a
world where you're not supposed to
discriminate against someone on the
basis of a college degree you are
allowed to evaluate them for the
concrete skills they have or don't but
you're not allowed to ask what school
they went to
wouldn't that be a different world maybe
that would be a better world right so
that we step one step two is probably
again being more friendly rather than
afraid of human agency mmm-hmm and
number three would be viewing knowledge
as positive right
I said earlier it's not useful to be
afraid of the future it's best to study
the future
I think we've inadvertently become
afraid of knowledge we now believe that
you know there was forbidden knowledge
and we tasted of the fruit maybe back in
1945 with the first atomic bomb maybe
earlier you know we've we've eaten the
fruit we're chewing it we're processing
it let's not have it be poisonous for us
and let's not be afraid of eating more
fruit yep yep right I think we need we
need nourishment if anything in terms of
our understanding of the universe not
not a fast a fast is not the right way
to solve this yeah knowledge in its
daily proportions with the updated most
updated skillsets emotional intelligence
is a massive one understanding
artificial intelligences as an
implication of society biotech Neurotech
blockchain technology right right yeah
because if we can get kids to understand
those technologies and the way that
decentralization will impact
civilization yeah I think that's a
massive plus for our global harmony so
those would be maybe some of the skills
I want to ask you about the way that you
form your analysis of civilizations and
how they prosper or fail in this idea of
a lineage of knowledge what the
methodologies are we talked about
critical thinking as one of these very
interesting principles of methodology
and these last couple of images that we
have kind of give people an idea of like
a if historically where people come from
write some of the greatest founders of
the United States of America and the
lines of code that we have also older
civilizations ancient civilizations
which one was this this is a room this
is from serations column yeah okay yeah
this one's Roman though and the other
one is that Egypt is this this is a blue
symbol it's a temple you know towards
the end of the Late Bronze Age
commissioned by ramses ii this is right
before their civilization collapsed -
it's right before the Bronze Age
collapse in what country now
Egypt is a dealership we have a Rome and
we have the United States America say
yeah yeah yeah so this is kind of
it's kind of funny though to see like
250 years ago versus a thousand years
ago or two thousand years ago and kinda
yeah so teach us about how you take
these methodologies and lineages and
analyze current civilizations well well
first to give a context I think that
civilization is gone through multiple
iterations we can make an argument as to
you know which civilizations are truly
distinct or not but the configuration of
civilization and therefore of humanity
on this planet has been notably
different it's gone through several
iterations each of these iterations each
of these societies has failed eventually
you know they've been either destroyed
or transformed beyond recognition not
always for the better each Society on
its own terms had institutions that are
unique to it
these unique institutions were often the
basis of a body of knowledge that was
accumulated by the society so in a very
strong way the foundations of society
rests in particular lineages of
knowledge upon which institutions are
built that then formed the skeleton and
the framework of the society as a whole
yeah if you are an individual in Egypt
in Rome in America today in a
philosophical sense you are radically
free in a practical sense different
things are rewarded different things are
possible there are different machines in
your environment I'm not just talking
about iPhones I'm talking about machines
such as will you have a trial by jury
yes right I'm talking machines about can
you go and find a spiritually
transformative experience in the temple
of rock yeah right these are machines in
a you know there was the recent tragedy
of notre dam burning mature dom is one
way to think about it it's a big old
useless stone building another way to
think about it is 800 years ago people
found the transformation of individual
consciousness and community culture so
important they chose to stop and build a
building out of stone for a hundred
years yeah yeah and if you go into one
of these great cathedrals even today
perhaps you you you you appreciate or
you don't
organized religion or politics or
whatever but you can't deny it's
creating changes and you merely by
walking through it
so is that perhaps an advanced
technology that we have lost what is the
last truly transformative and
inspirational building we have both
perhaps there was a lineage of knowledge
there an understanding of human
psychology paired with an understanding
of architecture that is a kind of
thought we no longer can access now
modern-day the modern world knows many
things the Romans and the Egyptians
didn't but sometimes it's the other way
around now talking about these
methodologies right when we think of
lineages people often imagine that this
is like well you write down something
into a book now this knowledge is safe
forever I am more interested in well
what allowed you to write the book in
the first place the most interesting
kind of knowledge is the kind where you
can transfer the creativity or the
generators or the tacit implicit
expertise that allowed you to produce an
impressive intellectual artifact such as
a completed book a solved equation a
particular engineering challenge
overcome in other words I'm saying not
only should we want to understand the
engineering solutions used by say rocket
scientists working for NASA in the 1960s
we should understand and know how those
rocket scientists if transported to 2019
would solve completely new engineering
challenges correct what we want is the
architects and designers or people who
have captured their spirit and their
understanding of the cathedrals of
France to build the new cathedrals or
new buildings or new concert halls with
modern materials
what is Aristotle's view on artificial
intelligence is a very interesting
question it's funny here and if we if we
had a coherent lineage of knowledge
there would be a student of Aristotle
that today could answer that question
meanwhile modern philosophy has devolved
into a sort of study of the ashes rather
than a preservation of the flame people
had very intricate opinions as to what
exactly Plato or subtle meant by X or Y
or Z they don't seem to apply that
thought system to new things we do have
some preserved lineages of course there
are many mathematical lineages right now
that are
alive Gauss in the 19th century had many
students each of them exceptional
mathematicians in turn and you have
famous examples such as Paul Erdos yeah
who would go around and he would say my
mind is ready he would show up at your
door
there would be an intense collaboration
between air doctrine and mathematicians
yeah these collaborations were so
productive that today people talk about
the ER - number correct as to how many
how many degrees of separation from
arash are you totally yeah how can we
recreate that flame right ology
preservation right right where again
preservation is not embalming like you
might do with a mummy it's more that you
know how can we create offspring yeah -
genius what is the what is the
intellectual offspring of Gauss yeah you
know who's the intellectual offspring of
say you know I know like Jim's father
someone a Discoverer of DNA in it seems
as though another one of the ways to
potentially phrase this would be to
think about applying a Pareto
distribution to the hundred billion
humans that build civilization right
identify the 20% of them that built 80%
of civilization and then zonin
double-click on the 20% and look at
their skill sets
what were their skill sets what were
their processes and then potentially
take as much as we can from that and
embed it into our current skill sets and
processes I like the way that you
described that that we have this
foundation of knowledge then we have
institutions and then the institutions
sort of build the frameworks in which we
live as individuals yeah and then of
course this goes right back meet you as
an individual can create new knowledge
the change is the institutional
framework that changes both yours and
other lives if the individual is
empowered to their fullest creative
potential right right right
and if there is a structural thing
preventing the creation of new knowledge
this is a civilization that is eating
its seed corn yeah and I feel that I
fear that we're accidentally going to
wander into an equilibrium where we are
eating the seed corn where we make
everyone brush their teeth every morning
and their phone buzzes at them if they
don't you know if we have a social
credit score you know what would have
Alonso
credits Corbin when he was 20 right what
would have Winston Churchill's social
spread at credit score been when he was
30 or 40 right the ability to make
mistakes and bounce back from mistakes
is vital in the learning process and if
we don't afford this to ourselves as
human beings well maybe the algorithms
are still learning but we're not yeah
yeah oh so much good to take from the
conversations that we have on
civilization and yeah but there's also
so much bad it all really depends on how
you interpret it I'm just saying it's a
good point Ron you can be you can be
positive but it just seems so bleak I
mean we're talking about how do we
educate a new generation but are you
aware there's something among us that
doesn't want smart people critical
thinkers to question authority to speak
truth to power
there is something obviously among us to
everything you're suggesting is this is
just an adversary so then the question
to propose would be what what do you
think is that force among us that is so
pushing away critical thinking with a
dark villain Darth Vader well it's a
very interesting question right I think
I tend to view that you know there's a
good there's a good quote by napoleon
never attribute to malice
we're in cop you know never attribute
the inaction to malice when incompetence
will do yeah so first off I think
there's a lot of incompetence I do also
think there's obviously there you know
there's malicious systems that exist I
think it's very difficult to look at
something like the history of the 20th
century and not conclude there is some
sort of like malicious or perverse
aspect I think it's probably baked into
human nature to some extent and I think
we're in a process of
harmonizing overcoming healing it really
depends which sort of philosophy which
sort of code to use your terminology you
ascribe to but you kind of have to
grapple with this reality right there is
there is this there's perhaps like a
shadow in the human heart yeah and you
know the human heart has projected
itself onto the world and you know we
need to we need to figure out how to
empower the best parts of ourselves so
I'm more focused I tend to be more
focused on building the positives on
building things that I I can study and
knowingly this a good make the best of a
dystopian future earlier in the program
I was trying to wrap I think I think
it's good to view the world with
equanimity and realism right
I think realism without wallowing in
despair that's that's the it's the
golden middle path that almost no one
reaches we either want to go away into
mania and forget about some aspects of
reality we don't like or we want to go
into depression because depression
absolves you of the need to act I'm your
your crush you're like oh this is such a
big problem well thank God it's a it's
an unsolvable problem because if it was
a hard solvable problem then I would
have to get out of bed yeah correct yeah
this is very interesting when you go
into the extremes of those right you
tend to have inaction as a default and
II think the inaction is an inaction of
thought as well you choose not to build
models you choose not to think
critically in a very real sense you talk
what's the dark villain it's like I
think it's merely the things that enable
us to excuse ourselves from choosing to
thank and choosing to act I think it
ultimately requires our decision to not
act and to not learn it can be
facilitated even in malicious ways but
ultimately I think that power remains
with with with humans Reid if we had a
further stake in the education of every
seed and in the nutrition of every seed
that decided child that's born into the
world if we all have a stake in it to be
a critical thinker and for them
be fully realized with something like a
big history that this type of stuff with
their own creative explosion and
endeavoring I think we could um we could
see a lot more successful gains in our
world
before we move on can we that we have a
viewer watching Andrew yes he just wants
to know he was watching the other day
when we had a couple of weird chicks on
we can't really say that anymore Andrew
but he wants to know what Kiev is this
channel can we answer him oh oh Andrew
Andrew hey welcome to simulation our
show features different leaders at the
edge of their fields and we try and make
that content as fun and relatable and
educational as possible and so this is
everything from entrepreneurs scientists
artists educators across different
fields so thanks for tuning in and
asking Andrew and thanks for stumbling
upon our content based on some
recommendation algorithm likely from
YouTube look at that if you thought what
CF is a sham this is funny because it's
also its realism without wallowing oh
yeah yeah of the good yeah yeah this is
this is very also interesting because
the question I want to ask you this so
recursive is your cell phone camera you
know I know there are some people who
love it but I absolutely hate it every
time I do it okay we but I love the
conversation we got I love the
conversation about the cameras we have
to ask because this is probably an
update from your last answer and we just
had a very quick glimpse into the
simulation has from last year as you've
developing your your thoughts do you
feel as though we're in a simulation
that's very interesting I still think we
are definitely always in a social
simulation I think we're a Fi and we
take for granted all these conventions
that surrounds us conventions such as it
is good to discriminate against people
on the basis of a college degree that
was granted probably on the nepotistic
basis rather than a basis of merit there
was a recent scandal at Harvard horse
yeah right and we also consider things
the concept of having a job instead of
perhaps having the unity between work
and leisure or perhaps concepts such as
you know it's things aren't really
knowable I should just you know let the
mystery exist out there in the world
rather than choosing to learn and to
investigate right I can't really
speculate that much about metaphysical
foundations of our world simulation
hypothesis as such seems very plausible
you know what is the substrate on which
our reality runs maybe it's you know a
very advanced computer chip like the one
we saw earlier on a massive massive
compute perhaps it's implemented in in
mathematics itself and mathematics is
the only thing that's real and there's
some sort of platonic idealism where the
forms are more real than the emanation
of the forms those are good questions to
try to grapple with
I think people derive a lot of epistemic
philosophical and psychological value
out of grappling with those questions
but I don't feel qualified to give an
answer so that's why I limit my answer
to the social dimension mm-hm I feel I
understand these structural dynamics
really well and I've invest a lot of
years of work into doing if only more
people understood
I have not qualified to give an answer I
think the world needs a little more of
that that's true but thank you for that
I really liked the quote earlier too
about not only are we saying I don't
know which is very important but also
the napoleon quote about ascribing the
two ascribing to malice what ignorant
would have been correct line as a
description I'll correct and that can be
also thought of as Occam's razor yes
yeah the ignorance is potentially even
simpler solution than trying to make a
convoluted story about malevolence being
what's actually at play right very
interesting and then let's see if you've
updated your answer on what's the most
beautiful thing in the world
interesting
I think discovering the truth is the
most beautiful thing in the world I
think that's that's this lovely and the
fun part about truth is well you can
arrive at it together with other people
so you can get the human connection
element out of the joint discovery of
truth in a very deep very profound way
that's what's up
you know it's a collaborative process
right - true right yeah you can't do it
yourself there's too much to figure out
yeah yeah
so I'm was super fun having you on for
round two you're such a synthesizer and
you know it really it really makes it
hard to pick and choose what to study
I'm sure you found this to be something
that's hard as well as when we code when
we interview you it's hard to pick what
what to talk about and I hope we did a
good job for those that are that are
viewing that are trying to get something
powerful from analysis of why
civilizations prosper versus fail thank
you so much for coming onto the show
it's good being here around - really
appreciate it yeah thanks everyone for
tuning in at home we would love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode thanks for all those that
were proposing questions throughout and
also we would love for you to support
the artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in you know support simulation
our links are below support the ones in
your communities as well share the
content with other people get them
talking about why civilizations collapse
versus succeed huge shout out to Ron
Vargas our producer and director thank
you very much and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon
[Music]
[Music]